let's bring in arizona attorney general
mark brnovich she's also a senate
candidate and just returned from
visiting the border yesterday general
brnovich thanks for joining us
what did you see
well i have been down to the border
numerous times and we are losing
adjectives to describe the anarchy and
chaos that's going on i was down there
talking to uh our dear friends the
chiltons they've been down there for
five generations and they will tell you
they've never seen it this bad and it
was as a result of the bite
administration failing to build the
border wall they have ms-13 gang members
they have hundreds of people crossing
their property
every day and as a result of that we
know when border patrol apprehends folks
illegally crossing they get out of the
field and that allows the drug cartels
and the terrorists then to basically go
right through and bring thousands of
pounds every month of drugs into our
country and allow terrorists to slip
through the safety net so we just noted
in that report from bill millusion that
the president has never been to the
border what would you tell him if he
were to come down
well it's a sad state of affairs when
the president has been to more hunter
biden art
exhibits than he has to our southern
border because americans are dying right
now as a as a result of the failed
policies of the binding administration
literally last year i invited him i
invited vice president harris who used
to be a state ag i've invited secretary
of yorkers to come meet with us to talk
to us and i think the biden
administration president biden needs to
come here so he can see firsthand the
damage his policies have brought not
only to arizona but to the entire united
states of america i want to put up the
numbers because they are
staggering really between october and
may uh 2021 to 2022 67 000 folks
were apprehended at the border from uh
el salvador 155 000 from guatemala
137 000 from honduras
560 000 from mexico but then there is
the category called other
616 000 people from other nations we're
talking about china we're talking about
really countries from all over the globe
what does that say to you general
brnovich
well it says or it proves the point i've
been making and trying to make in
federal court that the byte
administration has decriminalized and
incentivized people breaking the law and
so these aren't people coming here to
you know be housekeepers or work as
bartenders as a result of these policies
you have literally people on the terror
watchlist coming in you have the cartels
flooding our country with thousands of
pounds of illegal drugs every single
month so americans are dying as a result
of these failed policies and we're also
paying the cost not only in lives but
we're paying the cost and treasure as a
result of all the social services
everything from you know health care to
housing to to food stamps the binding
administration is trying to give to
people that are illegally or violating
our laws there were 19 hijackers on 911
and we know the damage that they caused
now we've got 50 people apprehended who
are on the terrorist watch list the
federal terrorist watch list
but that doesn't uh include people who
might have gotten away those are the
people who were apprehended there were
440 000
known got aways during the eight months
from october of 21 to may of 22 and you
have to wonder okay they ran away they
obviously escaped law enforcement that's
55 000.
55 000 a month
what do you think those people are up to
well
john let's put this in perspective for
folks
just just you know those numbers you're
talking about that's more than the
entire population of a place like
buffalo new york i mean so these are
astronomical amount of people that a
thousand a day in the tucson sector here
in arizona alone they're just slipping
into our country we know that the biden
administration is welcoming folks here
that are here illegally so you end up
having a situation you have to ask
yourself if someone could basically walk
across the border and we've seen this
carrying their carry-on bags and luggage
and surrender to homeland security and
then basically be let out in the country
what are these people doing that are
going through 100 plus degree
temperatures trekking through 19 20
miles of desert in places like arizona
and south texas what intention do they
have and i will tell you you don't need
to be a rocket scientist to figure out
that those people are coming here to do
bad things and whether that's crime in
our inner city whether it's flooding our
neighborhoods with drugs or whether it's
god forbid an act of terrorism the blood
of dead americans is on the hands of joe
biden in the bite administration
arizona attorney general mark brnovich
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now